The first texture optimization I want to talk about
has to deal with using streaming virtual textures
as an alternative way to stream textures for your project
in from disk.
Now, the reason I bring this up
is traditionally Unreal Engine
has used MIP-based streaming.
With this streaming-based method,
an entire object actually needs
to be rendered even if a single pixel of that object
is visible.
So let's take a mountain range
that's off in the distance.
We have this mountain range that's really massive,
and the user can just see a single pixel
of that mountain range.
We have to render that entire mountain range mesh
even if we can just see that one pixel.
And this can be inefficient, especially as our scenes
grow in size and complexity.
With streaming virtual texturing,
we can actually just see that one pixel
and not have to worry about loading
all of that additional data.
Now, again, this is the default option
for any new Unreal Engine 5 project.
But if you do not have it enabled
or you enabled it after the fact,
you can enable virtual texturing
by first going up to Rendering
and then enable virtual texturing support.
Once you've done this, you will need to restart the editor.
Once the editor has restarted, depending
on what you have done previously,
you'll need to do one of two things.
First, you'll need to either convert any existing textures
to utilize virtual textures by selecting all those textures,
right-clicking on them inside of the content browser,
and then converting them to virtual texture.
Unreal will automatically convert all textures
to use virtual textures.
It's a simple check mark box.
And again, this can be done for you automatically
by selecting all the textures you want
in the content browser, right-clicking on them,
and then from the menu,
selecting Convert to Virtual Texture.
When you utilize a texture or want to know
if a texture you're about to use is a virtual texture,
it will have a VT logo
on the lower right-hand corner of the texture,
as we can see on the slide in front of us.
Once we're using that virtual texture
inside of a material,
we'll need to make sure that the sampler type
is set to Virtual Color, Grayscale,
Alpha, Normal, Masked, Linear Color,
Linear Color, Grayscale.
The reason I'm bringing this up
is Unreal Engine 5 will automatically apply this setting
to any new texture samplers that utilize virtual textures,
but existing materials
may have to have their samplers converted.
So just make sure that the converted option
matches the original input in that texture sampler.